Jamie Authorities say this is now
a criminal investigation.
Several fires raging.
Now down this street, smashing,
grab flash mob at a Nordstrom,
Took Police the number
of homeless people on the streets
and in shelter, medical treatment for minors,
which has surprise attack within Israel's borders.
People are for a
And an angel of the Lord appeared to them
and the glory of the Lord shown around them,
and they were filled with fear.
And the angel said to them, fear not for behold.
I bring you good news of great joy.
Good news of great joy. Yeah. What a phrase, right?
I I think we all need some of that right now, don't we?
Some good news. Uh, I think we could all long for
that great joy, that sense of deep abiding joy.
Of course, we need that.
Well, that's what we've been focused on the last few
Sundays, is we've looked at this scene from 2000 years ago
where we celebrate what we call the incarnation, which is
God the Son, taking on flesh to be with his people
full of grace and truth dwelling among us.
Now, here's the backstory to that.
For thousands of years, God's people had been
waiting for something.
They had been waiting and longing for the Messiah,
for the savior, for the deliverer to come.
God had promised to send him, and they were waiting for it.
Yet, what they didn't fully realize was that
that savior was coming not merely as a political messiah
or a, uh, a physical social messiah.
He was coming primarily first
and foremost as a spiritual messiah.
And as he changed hearts,
his kingdom values would then show up in the
world around them.
But to a group of oppressed
and seemingly forgotten people back then,
that would've been good news of great joy, right?
That he was not only coming, but he had come.
But it's just as true for us today.
See, I know that Christmas is often characterized as a,
a joy-filled, happy time filled with lights
and presents and hallmark movies and, and sugar plums.
Like I don't even know what a sugar plum is.
Anybody tell whatever that is.
But, but that's what we kind of project out
and culture demands of us.
But what I know from my story is that many
of us walk in here today with, with some pain, uh, with some
feeling of sadness, with some oppression, maybe with,
with whatever feeling of being outcast.
You might feel a forgottenness in your life
that you have felt.
Plus many of our eyes have succumbed to the constant cycle
of seemingly bad news that we see on social media
and on the news stations.
And, and we see that and, and we think that's all there is.
That's why we need good news of great joy just as much
as anyone else does, just as much as they did back then,
which is thankfully exactly what the angel said
to the shepherds on that night.
Luke 10, Luke two 10 says, fear not for behold.
I bring you good news of great joy that will be
for all the people.
All the people, us too.
Good news of great joy.
So what I wanna do for a few minutes is focus on, on
what the angels said to the shepherds that night.
What was their perspective on the Messiah's arrival?
But I also want us to consider those shepherds a little
bit towards the end.
'cause I think we can be encouraged by what God chose
to do there and why he did what he did.
And so first, again, notice what the angels said as he came
to the shepherds announcing Jesus' birth.
Listen to what the angel said.
Behold, I bring you good news. Fear not I.
Behold, I bring you good news of great joy that will be
for all the people, for unto you is born this day in the
city of David, a savior who is Christ the Lord.
And this will be a sign for you.
You will find a baby wrapped in swaddling costs,
lying in a manger.
Now, that was not only from the one angel, as he showed up
to these shepherds, the, the curtain
of the heavens splits open and this shining one enters in
and says this to the shepherds.
But then a multitude of angels appeared
shining like stars praising God.
And here's what they said. You heard the choir sing it.
Glory to God in the highest
and on earth, peace among those with whom he is pleased.
Now, just stop for a second.
Can you imagine being in that field like
how overwhelmed you would be?
You're in the dark, you're in the quiet, bleeding sheep
around you, and it's totally silent,
and all of a sudden the heavens split
and light shines
and you hear these amazing, overwhelming,
deafening truths.
But this was how God chose
to declare his son's earthly birth
to a few smelly shepherds in an empty field outside
of a tiny town in Bethlehem.
Like that's, that's stunning, first
and foremost, that God would choose to do it that way.
We'll talk again here in a second about that.
But, but what did God say through the angels?
Well, first he said, don't be afraid.
I don't know about you, but if I was in that moment,
I would be terrified of what just happened.
It seems like every time in scripture that an angel shows up
to a person, they have to say, don't be afraid, right?
'cause you would be, But why?
Notice he says, why don't be afraid. Why?
Because I bring you good news of great joy
that will be for all the people.
Now, thankfully he explains the good news
or else we wouldn't know what it is.
The good news is that unto you, meaning for you, given
as a Christmas present to you,
you might say A savior has been born in David's city,
Bethlehem, David's hometown.
That goes back to the legacy of the generations.
And it says, that's not just any baby that's born there,
the Savior, but that's the Christ, the Messiah,
the one you've been waiting for,
the promised one from ages past, fulfilling the prophecies.
He is born and he's the Lord already.
That's one of the the,
when you think about the Christmas carols we sing, you need
to deeply think about those lyrics.
We're gonna sing one here in a moment
as we light these candles.
It's a familiar one. You might have missed it,
but it says Jesus Lord at thy birth.
That's what this is talking about.
Meaning he already was,
he always has been the Lord at his birth.
It means he already was.
I love how HB Charles a, a preacher in Florida, he put
that idea, he said, many babies have become king.
Only once has a king become a baby.
The king already was the Lord. He became a baby.
And if the shepherds had any question about any of this,
which you can imagine,
they would've been a little overwhelmed.
But if they had any question about this,
the angel gave them a sign, a proof, an action
that would validate the claims about someone.
So they say, here's what you need to do.
Follow God's leading to find this baby,
lying in a feeding trough, wrapped in strips of fabric.
They called s swaddling colos.
Here's why they said that, because just up in verse seven,
you saw it happen here, illustrated.
She gave birth, Mary gave birth to her firstborn son,
wrapped him in swaddling cloths, laid him in a manger
because there was no place for them in the end
again, only one angel said all that to the shepherds.
But then so many showed up,
this heavenly choir showed up again singing
what verse 14 said, glory to God
and the highest on earth peace among those
with whom he's pleased.
So this, this baby, this Lord Christ, he is the Savior,
the prince of peace.
Isaiah nine predicted 700 years earlier.
This is the baby born to us.
And he gives peace as God pleases.
Okay? So here's the question. How do we get that peace
that he is bringing?
Because in our sin, every one of us, we are God's enemies.
He's a holy God. We're not so, we are his,
uh, his opposition.
You might say his enemies. And so how do we get that peace?
Well, Romans five, one answers the question,
since we have been justified by faith, we have peace
with God through our Lord Jesus Christ.
Alright? Do you notice the conditions?
It's through our Lord Jesus Christ.
That means you cannot have peace with God
by your own efforts, by climbing up a ladder
of good works to get to God.
You can't make it.
It's only through his perfect life, death
and resurrection in your place that you put your trust,
your faith, your eternal hope in what he has done for you.
That's then when he justifies you,
meaning he makes you right before God.
He takes enemy separated
and he says, no, now you are a friend.
As if you'd lived Christ perfect life yourself.
He makes you a beloved child.
That's what he does by faith.
Listen, if you're, if you're here
and you don't have the assurance that you have that kind
of peace with God, Don't leave today.
Please come talk to one of us up here at the front as soon
as we're done, or somebody you came with
and say, I don't, I don't know if I have that.
We would love to talk with you.
Be honored to talk with you about that.
And so, so that's the angel's perspective,
the heavenly perspective on the Messiah.
But I also wanna take a moment
and think about those shepherds.
See, God could have sent those angels to anyone.
He could have announced it to the kings and the palaces.
He could have showed up at the temple
to the religious leaders who'd been
supposedly following God.
And he could have announced it there.
He could have gone to this massive crowd in Jerusalem,
gathered, had he could have said, here's the Messiah.
Who did the angels come to though to the shepherds,
to the ones walking in the darkness of the night,
but also who were walking in the darkness of society.
He came to the least of the least to the last and the least.
He came to them.
And we could imagine all kinds of reasons why.
But I love what one author wrote about why she believes God
chose to announce the birth first to these men.
The Bethlehem Shepherds did not deconstruct the glory
that they were chosen to witness.
You might imagine. This is what she says.
Shouldn't the Savior be born into wealth?
I mean, did the angels really mean a manger?
No, they carried not their doubts,
but their wonder to the baby, offering joy,
not speculation, received, they received the gift
with no contingencies.
See, that's what God's looking for.
God's looking for those of us who recognize
that we need Him, who are in awe of God,
that he would do something so gracious.
For those of us who are so sinful, he's looking for those
who know that they don't have it all together.
Those who know that they're not always in the circle, those
who are beyond the places of power, those
who have messy lives, those
who are sitting in the darkened fields of life
with their eyes lifted, listening for the heavenly song.
Listen, if that's you today, if that's you today,
hear me, God sees you.
God sees you, God still comes for you.
Even now, even here,
this heavenly song still
echoes in the darkness, in our darkness.
Glory to God, in the highest
and on earth, peace among those with whom he's pleased.
So this Christmas, Let's not get so wrapped up
in what the world is trying to sell us
and miss what God is trying to give us.
The Savior came to bring us home.